All right, we're starting the week off with
something a little wacky, something I wish
we weren't actually having to start the week
off.
The New York Times editorial board has written
an article called Ease Up on the Executive
Actions.
Joe with the subtitle, President Biden is
right to not let his agenda be held hostage,
but legislating through Congress is a better
path.
And in this article, The New York Times editorial
board says correctly that, quote, A week into
his presidency, Mr Biden has issued a raft
of executive orders and other actions already.
He is committed to rejoining the Paris climate
change agreement ended the Muslim travel ban,
canceled the permit for the Keystone XL pipeline,
rescinded funding for and halted construction
on the wall at the southern border, reaffirmed
the Deferred Action for Childhood Arrivals
program mandated wearing a mask, wearing on
federal grounds, moved to end the federal
government's reliance on private prisons,
reversed the ban on transgender military service,
and called for agency assessments aimed at
advancing racial equity, just to name a few.
The coming days will bring more such action.
But this isn't that good, they say.
And they're concerned.
They say, not just because executive orders
don't create law and can be changed by future
by future presidents, which is true, but because,
quote, executive actions are far more ephemeral
and easily discarded than legislation which
can set up a whipsaw effect as each president
scrambles to undo the work of his predecessor,
just as Mr. Trump said about reversing as
many of President Barack Obama's directives
as possible, Mr. Biden is now working to reverse
many of Mr. Trump's reversals with executive
orders.
There is always another presidential election
just a few years off, threatening to upend
everything.
This is one of the silliest New York Times
editorials I've seen.
First of all, these executive orders are a
good start until permanent legislation can
be passed, if it can.
And the if right now is arguably more important
than it's ever been, given that there is a
Republican Party that doesn't even pretend
to care about policy.
What it Marjorie Taylor Green run on, other
than just Trump ism and owning the Libs, what
did Lauren Bobert run on other than Trump
ism and owning the Libs?
This is one of the two year period during
which Democrats have control of the House,
Senate and White House, and they may have
no choice but to go at everything by themselves.
So we'll talk more about that.
Secondly, these executive orders are a signal
that hopefully Joe Biden is going to do everything
he can of the things he promised to do, regardless
of whether he has Republican support or not.
And remember, he was elected based on the
things he promised to do.
And number three, this reeks of status quo
ism from The New York Times.
The New York Times editorial board doesn't
like that Joe Biden isn't using the powers
he has after being elected by voters because
it's too much change.
What and fourth, much of what Joe Biden is
doing isn't really a dramatic change anyway
beyond getting us back to the pre Trump situation.
So in a way, like I hate to say it, but Joe
Biden's executive orders are, in
a sense, getting
us
back
to the
status quo.